on this international women's day two
important things to remember to support
women-owned businesses and of course
prioritize self-care
that's right well rocky thea's has more
from a local shop where i understand you
can do both
welcome to sweet bubble bath confections
it's what i like to call
a bubble bath bakery because when you
walk in
you see all of these desserts and you
actually look like you're in a bakery
but you're not you're not making cookies
you're making soap we're making so
so tell us a little bit about this local
shop and first of all i just love
that it's family and woman owned it is
family owned we've been around
in this location for about 10 years from
our grandmother
to my mom my sisters my dad actually
helps out as well here in the shop
men deserve self-care too everybody
so what do you guys offer so we offer
pretty much everything
um from old-fashioned soaps to
bath bombs to sugar scrubs to
our confetti cakes that we have up here
yes so bath bombs and sugar scrubs but
all with a very
delectable delicious twist i might add
so let's talk about
this product right here because it looks
like cake but please i repeat do not eat
it do not bite the bubble bath cake so
those are our confetti cakes they're
also
um bubble bath bars bowl bath in the bar
form look at that
you can break it apart and throw it in
your bath under running water so what do
you do you go
go full board let's do an entire bar
we've created some bubble baths for you
all
right it's like a little science project
wow okay so what happens when you put it
in
what goes on so when you put it in it
will actually soften up
i like to use it under running water you
get a lot of
bubbles um it's like a cleansing bar
look at that very soft and soothing wow
and it smells good too
oh yes oh my goodness okay so yeah okay
got a little messy
no worries we it's what happens when
you're in a bake shop okay
all right so so this is it's not
moisturizing it's just for
decoration and gentle cleansing right
gentle cleansing
okay okay so now let's move on to
moisture because that's a very important
factor in self-care yes absolutely
and your bath bombs help with that our
bath bombs definitely do
this is a bath bomb very popular right
now but i've never really understood
what they do so let's talk about it
so they soften moisturize the skin um
once you put them in the water you can
kind of see what they're doing there
a lot of bubbles compared to our bubble
bar over here
it has the shea butters and cocoa
butters really really good on your skin
to moisturize and soften
love to use them at the end of the day
taking a bath yes um with
with our bath bombs here and i want to
add you know
taking a bath is definitely a luxury and
something we should do
but also shower is very important too so
coming up later in the show
we're going to show you how to enhance
your shower experience right
we'll be back